Let's go with a simplified
version of the whole thing.
We're gonna talk about
simplify BRDF mouse. Well,
there's going to be the MBN BRDF.
How does it look like? Well first,
first on the last side,
I see I,
this is intensity. Well
what is this? Well,
no one knows because we have not radiance,
not something very physical here.
This is going to be the simplified
version of the whole rendering equation.
Basically a bunch of packs. If you love
something that is vastly simplified,
it doesn't really have a physical meaning.
It doesn't have physical units,
but it works. It's beautiful and it's a
good way to understand what's going on.
So the intensity that we
measure is going to be an NBN,
the product of an MBN
coefficient of an object.
This is dependent of the
object. This means that, uh,
this means something like
the color of the object
and the eye is going to be the intensity,
the ambient intensity of a scene
or the light source. And uh,
later on you're going to be talking
about why this is interesting.
So this is an example.
We have a blue object over here.
And it's the same color everywhere.
Why?
Because the farm in 1000
depends on anything.
There's just one for efficient that's
multiplied by this intensity of the scene.
So that's an NBN shading.
Uh, what else is dark?
There's the diffuse BRDF.
This is what we compute
is a diffuse coefficient.
What is the diffuse color?
The diffuse Albido of this thing.
And there's going to be a product ofL
and. M. This is what we did before.
Do you feels objects look like that?
Uh,
please raise your hand if you have ever
done any kind of diffuse lung version
model in graphics. Okay, excellent. Great.
And just another thing, this, uh,
diffuse cooperation is the very least RGB.
Okay.
So this is how much light is not absorbed
on every different wavelength because
I cannot describe collars in one number
at the very least RGV or a continuous
spectrum
just for the record.
And now it's looking better because I
can more or less see where the light
source is with for this fuel shading.
Uh,
there's also a specular BRDF
when I compute is the V. Dot.
Hard times of specular coefficient.
And v is the vector pointing towards
the viewer. And our is to reflected,
there's going to be examples of that.
So just that you see the formula and
there's an l which has a shyness factor,
uh, in the next assignment you
will play with this yourself.
So for now I will keep this a secret,
but this exact with us and what side we're
going to junk food is because I would
like to ask a question later
on and you're going to find out
the solution. Excuse me. So this is
how the specular highlights look.
And if I add up all of these things
MBL and diffused and specular,
I get some complex looking,
a model that looks something that is,
that approximates a physical reality.
So I just simply add all
these terms of, uh, okay,
well I have something like this here
and I have on purpose removed the light
source from this image.
But probably everyone can tell where
the light source is expected to be.
All right, so raise your hand if
you know her the lies or should be.
Okay, cool. Where should it be?
Above exactly.
Exactly.
So it's going to be above is fierce
and this is exactly where it is.
So these material models are
descriptive in the way he does that.
I get images that have some physical
meaning that resemble physical reality.
Well, let's, let's take a
look at an actual example. Uh,
the question is what would
this region look like?
The one that I marked like this pixel,
if pixels existed in the real world,
uh,
would it look the same if I moved my head
in reality and that sound that sounds
like you know, this, it
sounds like a tricky question.
Yeah, I have seen the answer.
Yes. Uh, well, uh, let's say that
this part is purely the fuse.
I don't see many specular reflections
in there. The fuse is l. Dot. M.
So light, lighter
direction, times to normal.
Does it change if I move my head?
Well, how do I answer this question?
You don't really need to see what
is in an equation. You are off. You,
you have to be aware of
what is not in there.
Does it change if I move my head,
raise your hand if you know the answer.
It's very apparent on many or few.
Yes,
yes. The change. If I
move with them, okay,
I'm going to change because the
specularity might move. Yes, that's,
that's very true. So it doesn't change
because we know that it doesn't change.
I mean the walls look the same.
Uh, if I, if I move around,
I mean not talking about shapes,
I'm talking about collars.
They don't change and mirror.
However it does change. Uh,
and the mathematical reason for this is
that the view direction is not in this
equation.
I can change the view of their actual
all I want and nothing will change in the
diffuse to be out here.
So this is like a general mathematical,
a trick or,
uh,
principles that you can use in a
number of different things. Don't just,
don't just look at what
variables are in there. Uh,
tried to think of variables,
what you would imagine that
would be there and okay,
why are they missing? And
that's, that's also information.
That's what they're not the only one
stamp at what is missing is valuable
information. So what about these
regions? These are specular highlights.
These are described by the
specular BRDF V. Dot. R.
So view indirection times there are
reflected a light direction and let's
actually compute what's going on.
So I would be interested in the intensity,
this fake something of this point
where this is a delight vector.
This is where it points to,
it is probably reflected somewhere there
because it comes in and it's an ideal
reflections. So it's gonna be
reflected in this direction.
And this is where I am just for example.
So I'm interested in V. Dot. R.
Well this is going to be a cosign.
Uh,
there is a small angle between the Emr.
So if there's a small lag
loan that's course sign of
a small number that's large,
that's goes to one
and that's going to be a huge
scalar product. Therefore,
this point is bright and
this is indeed broke.
And the question is, which is a
very easy to insert in a second,
is does it change if I move around,
does it change?
Obviously it does change
because v is in the equation.
And if I change this around in different,
uh,
for the specular BRDF,
this is going to be bright and just one
of my favorite intuitions of this leader
arm because otherwise
this is just letters.
This means how much am I
standing in the way of the life?
So a life lesson,
if you can't find the water droplets
on the floor after having a shower,
move your head around because that
specular if the windshield of a car is too
bright and it's, and you just can't take
it anymore, move your head around this,
this, this connects to the
physical reality around us.
And that's good tips in case you didn't
know that you need to move your hand
around, you brought down,
oh, now you're low. Okay.
So, uh, this is the, the,
the point where we can just for a second
stop and marvel at how beautiful things
we can create with such simple equations
and they're under a new equation is
going to be even looking to fold in
that lane infinitely more beautiful.
And there is some additional
beauty that you can think about.
And when you look at images like that,
okay, how will I shape this point?
Is this diffuse? If is the
specular, why does it look the way?
So you can,
if you nothing better to do.
You can think about these things
when on public transport, uh,
let's call this thing that
illumination equation.
This is the faith simpler version
of the rendering equation.
Now what is in there? Most of this
is familiar days and MBN chain term.
And then there's the diffuse l.
Dot.
M there is the specular veto are we add
all these together and we multiply this
by the amount of incoming light because
if there's no light sources in the scene,
there is no light.
Light is not coming from anywhere.
Therefore this is all divided by zero.
If there's a bright light
source that things get brighter.
So we multiply by this incoming light.
And what is important to know is that
this is only the direct effect of light
sources. Uh, this sounds a
bit esoteric at the moment,
but later on a few lectures down the road,
we're going to be all about indirect
illumination and Moody's life.
That and this is neglected and the
MBM term is used to make up for it.
You will see examples of this in
the next lecture and this is a crude
approximation but it's still beautiful.
It's easy to understand and it serves
as a stepping stone to solve the real
vendor mission.
Uh,
but this has not done one thing is that
if there are multiple light sources,
the scene is expected to be brighter.
So I would compute the whole
thing for multiple light sources.
So there's going to be a sum in there and
the inside the some lists that indexes
are the number of light sources.
Basically just,
I just didn't want to overcomplicate this.
Uh,
but still something is still
missing. This is, this is not done.
I arrived to a point,
I compute this specular ambient and
diffuse shading and I am not done.
Let's discuss how ray tracing
works and we'll find out.
So the first thing is that what you see
here is non trivial because what you
would imagine is that you start shooting
grace from the light source and then
some of the rays would make
up to make it to the camera,
to your eye and,
and most of them won't.
So we go with a simple,
uh,
optimization that we turned
the whole thing around.
And then we start tracing
grace from the camera.
Because if I start racing from there,
I can guarantee that I deem it raised
that are not wasted because the,
I'm not interested in the light
rays to not make it to the camera.
So if I started from there,
I can guarantee that this is
not wasted to computation.
So how do we do this?
There is this camera plane,
we will discuss how to construct such a
thing and we construct race through this
camera plane.
And what I'm interested in
is the projection of the
three d world to display.
This is what you will see on your monitor.
So I should raise from this camera and I
intersect this against objects that are
in the scene. I want to know where
is the light stopping, where,
what objects does it hit and
where does it get reflected?
So the second is
intersection with an objects.
I have to realize that it hits
this sphere. Then I stopped there.
I compute the Basie shaming turns
like the diffuse and the rest,
and then I don't stop there,
but I'm interested in where
the light is reflected.
I need to continue from
here and this light,
this light lightweight,
maybe reflected or refracted,
and I need some kind of recursion
in order to come from that for that.
And the recursion works
in the following way.
I stop at this point where I hit the ball,
the sphere,
and what I do is that I imagined that
this is now the starting point of the rain
and I'm shooting very outwards and I
start this ray tracing algorithm again.
So this is how the recursion works.
This was missing from the formula,
and this is just what the text version
of what I have set for those who are
reading this at home. And you're going
to deal with reflections for stuff.